c'est bienvenue pour ce nouveau stream
du jeudi alors je vais refaire comme
comme d'habitude le petit hosting je
vais faire comme tout comme d'habitude
le petit hosting sur la chaise vide
stream comme ça la section sur la chaîne
du stream pourront suivre aussi donc ce
soir c'est la reine francophone va la
préparer ensemble
alors on va faire les petites choses
qu'on doit faire en début de stream et
après on sera autour de trois minutes
comme ça on va lancer un truc là on est
bon comme ça on est sur le bon chat on
va sortir la fenêtre comme ça ça c'est
fait on va créer le tournoi ensemble
alors on va aller dans tournoi tournoi
en club chaise comme tv français à
rennes francophone qu'à lens 5 minutes
partie standard aujourd'hui 20h30 comme
ça ça c'est fait et par contre c'est pas
vrai c'est pas en suisse et en arène
donc ça cinq minutes aujourd'hui 20h30
duré deux heures pak tac tac tac tac ça
à mon avis c'est bon c'est fait c'est
parfait ça s'est créé déjà on a la reine
francophone mois laissé un peu les gens
arrivent et on va se faire deux trois
sessions de puzzle run par réussir à
refaire le design d'air j'ai oublié je
vous dis toujours que le puzzle rage je
sais pas sur le même c'est pas sûr
c'est pas c'est pas le même design que
le reste ça lui à pied si tweak salut
tonton j'espère que tu vas bien
et donc on va essayer de va et c'est
d'attendre que les gens arrivent qu'ils
puissent s'inscrire au tournoi et puis
on ira faire un peu de puzzle rush pour
le chat par contre faut absolument aller
sur sur le chat de la chaîne chasse
com/fr sinon je le vois pas j'ai quand
même ouvrir c'est une miss stream là
pour jeter un oeil pour récupérer les
gens qui pourraient aller mais du coup
je n'ai pas ouvert avant mais pour
récupérer les voix l'a accueilli au
caire qui s'abonnent pour un quatrième
mois à la chaîne mii stream donc merci
tonton donc je vais quand même le
récupérer jegham a récupéré les deux
chat pacte ac
là on est bon là on est bon là on est
bon là on est bons salua le papou et
salua thirion j'attends tout qui peuvent
inclure plus je suis un peu me chaut
fait j'ai fait plein de choses
aujourd'hui mais je suis en train de
récupérer petit à petit mon retard le
retard que j'ai pris à cause du match
pour le titre de champion du monde de
quatre scènes
caruana c'est du coup j'ai pris du
retard sur des choses que je devais
faire
cette façon est bien obligé de manger
automatiquement faut bien faire la
cuisine info que ce cabinet se fasse
mais on n'est pas très nombreux pour le
mot salut à sa neex multigaming pas non
plus je vois plusieurs jeux est
automatiquement donc je sais pas si les
gens s'inscrit là pour pour la reine
francophone du jeudi on a déjà deux
inscrits pour s'inscrire il faut aller
sur le foie les sur le lien du club du
club français alors attendez faut
retrouver le lien du club français club
ges comme tv français qui doit être la
up
le pack ou qu'il y est j'ai surkiffé le
dernier arena avec les nouveaux kiffe
les nouveaux guides gif de langue de l'
angoisse
tu as bien fait de te faire chier à les
faire
ouais le truc c'est que je leur fasse
parce que pour les directs a dû voir le
dernier sur you sur youtube en replay il
y était déjà les gifs peu importe mais
le truc c'est qu'ils se sont ils se sont
enlevés ils se sont enlevées faut que je
refasse tout c'est hyper pénible ça
prend du temps c'est pénible affaire
salut à tous et twitch twitch 6,26 je
vais bien mais coûte amarante écrite
which foutu comme ça c'est dur à lire du
coup du coup c'est difficile à lire donc
cet aréna francophone on en est où 1 3
inscrits allez on va s'inscrire aussi on
va être cadre du coup je n'imagine que
les gens s'inscrivent petit à petit donc
on a la liste des inscrits à droite on
va un petit peu le l'agrandir
un peu l'agrandir alors on va partir
quand même pour quelques petits puzzles
rush pour s'échauffer mais je me sens
pas en pleine forme là ça va être dur le
pesage annonce en fait un petit déjà
pour pour se chauffer alors ça ça va pas
aller comme ça peut aller rush c'est pas
super c'est m on va se mettre comme ça
attendez on va peut-être le maître comme
sale puzzle rush comment comment comment
le mettre
je pars commandes cadres et ce puzzle
auch
ok et la caméra du coup est ce que du
coup la monte à fond ok mais là car à
fond et on le lance on fait comme ça
c'est pas moche pas très esthétique mais
est ce qu'on peut faire autrement
est ce qu'on peut vraiment faire
autrement
voilà salue monsieur p soit mais je suis
pas un fan du pesage perso j'aurai
beaucoup fait à l'époque y avait quelque
chose qui existait et j'avais réussi à
être dans les premiers au classement
ressemblant mais je suis plus plu au
caire la semaine je pense qu'on va
mettre la caméra ici allez on lance on
lance un peu amorphe
est ce que la caf dans la caméra en plus
il sut permet de passer alors la mer en
dessous allons on est parti c'est la
dame prend 1,4 d'un projet 5 et on prend
un f6 tout reprend dame pour le moment
c'est facile et premier surface il bat
du couloir d'amd si ce matin en 1 dhabi
et 6 d'un machisme at d'amalfi dame g8
je suis lent pour le manque et prend des
cinq dames prend invite le sens que je
vois pas vite les choses bombe trois
bêtement et e2 et 1 dames puis on prend
et des cinq pour cette tour j'ai un
échec tout ranger quatre tons orangés
5,6 et le mas de pillsbury bad as me
prends des cinq bêtement dame 3,5
bêtement on va faire qui est points
bêtement lightning contre indication à
faire plonger de nom d'anne ici là je
bloque je bloque complètement tour de
c'était facile j'ai bloqué faut prendre
trois il faut prendre 17 et il n'y a pas
de match de l'autre côté c'est je suis
trop lent fou prend des deux tons france
pourquoi 6 x h 4 et ont réussi à mener
le fou bien placé d'un point 4 français
4 c'est facile h trois échecs ont des
visages de l'échec monde et vytorin f1
et agendas c'est simple ici tour j'ai un
échec ça marchait pas d'un pro systemat
en main comprend des vies et des deux le
pion parce qu'ils essaient 3 d'appoint
f4 ont gagné une pièce roi g7 et
battement d'aile français ok ok tout âge
de tout reprend des 4 je suis lent donc
et c5 puis champion prend je suis très
lent car il prend f7 food et 5 enfilade
ok y'a pas de menace
ça va juste que j'ai 61.8 et tout
reprend 17 d'un point à 8
je les ai vus j'ai vu plus vite saâf ici
ça et 3 des 4 et le fou va plus avoir de
casse tourbe et de fous des cinq pour
bercy seront à prendre et 5 fougerais de
fou prend 1 4% g7 et d'un français 4
s'était pas d'âme français 4
cette fois ci ce pion prend et tour
francs et il faut prendre cette sas et
tour à deux et d'un prince est ici c'est
d'un grand c'est cet pour ces huit tours
france est un
là j'ai cinq échecs foot pro f4 qui ont
pensé 3 ça c'était facile
et s'il faut changer cinq ans premier
d'un programme de sept matchs ça va
tranquille lasserrois de trois
oppositions roi qu'à 3 500 gagne les
pions ici on est québécois je peux pas
mince j'ai vu que j'étais cloué de bazar
fief cinq échecs roi b3 qui est tombé 5
tours détroit hockey ici le 4k lieu 5 à
j'ai voulu combler pour faire mieux
c'était quoi ici alors
ouais c'est bêtement reprend des 4 as
était encore plus simple
l'armée ok là j'ai fait 37 mais je suis
mou du genou et j'ai pas eu de bol sur
les docks gerra trait sur les deux que
j'ai raté j'ai pas une bonne année on
rejoue à la salle tout un match et sur
ok damas est mat tour des huit à l'aunis
clic c'est relou la france est trop
grande et 3 d'un projet de match d'impro
huit dames 5 comme quand des six c'est
facile quand juste du fou pour éviter le
père pète kg 3 turaci pas de greco
visiteront enfermement du fou enfilade
d'un match 4 pensait d'eux est elle la
dame a ici la mef trois échecs d'un
prochain dame f6 facile tout reprendre
et de ses matchs en main bref si ce
n'est pas ce qui est des sept matches
ici c'est juste tous rêvent de haies
dames ces deux facile si ces dames
francesca tonton des huit dames un
cadavre en d4 c'est simple ici c'est
tour des huit et mat du couloir de
l'autre côté
ici c'est qu'elle prend à croire qu'elle
prenait 3 x 3 maths c'est facile pour
prendre ces quatre qui est promu 6
fourchette
voilà ses pions prend jusqu'à et des
cinq ans
ok j'ai pas compris ici c'est juste
qu'il pointe 44.5 facile ici d'apprendre
les six d'alger sept matchs tranquillou
ici c'est tout rejet de fc sion prise en
passant waouh
là je bloque à sky pro f 5 et cavaliers
cet échec était prendrait 5
mais si ces dames b5 et on gagne le
fouet fa ici il il souffre ici c'est
tourbe et 3 probablement et enfin f3 et
avait décidé avec tour à tour amat ici
vous et 7 c'est juste pas atteint
ici je bloque c'est faux f4 et des six
non c'était des six f4
astellas même dans l'autre sens ici ces
dames g6 et fous fera je bloque là
encore who preuve cette non c'est pas
fou premier set c'était probablement
d'un match si c'est autre chose rage
était mauvais mais jean elie dur là
ouais je trouve plus âgés j'ai perdu le
mojo band façon je suis marc autant j'ai
perdu le mojo là c'est pas cinq mais je
n'arrivais pas à le trouver
steco à celui-là ravauder survendu
retrouver
west et tour des 3 j'ai perdu le mojo
bref je referme
[Musique]
j'ai le cerveau qui est lent bon allez
ça samat samad samat samat ouais ça me
dire c'est trop fatigué
trop fatigué ça venir plus à l'esprit
ces rongeurs
non c'était moi pour un jeu mais
qu'est-ce que je suis nul je fasse une
pause
ça vient plus à l'esprit a ici
c'est pas ça me saoule plus à l'esprit
c'est horrible c'est affreux faut que je
fasse une pause ok ça vient plus à
l'esprit saffres faut dire les
adversaires jouent pas trop aux échecs
avec les positions qui tourne à gauche à
droite en haut en bas tu as la tête qui
tourne au bout d'un moment
au bout d'un moment tu as la tête qui
tourne ok c'est juste prix ici way
[Musique]
ces cinq ok bon j'étais pas aussi
mauvais je pourrais faire mieux si
j'étais pas aussi mauvais je pourrais
faire mieux à ça ne vient pas à l'esprit
là non plus le cas c'est peut-être juste
si on prend un tampon fc cheikh est fou
prend 8 kuyl ans ça c'est un v8 3g trois
points f3 et puis on prend alors ils
vont aller jusqu'au matin supportable
d'un point qui prend ses sets et qu'il
prend à 8 4 à 5 et puis on prend que
c'est facile
ok ça c'est hyper simple si tu connais
c'est simple qui est des cinq c'est
simple je crois juste ok ça ses fruits
si c'est facile d'apprendre et si c'est
vrai que c'est une partie de tags
en tout cas c'est ressembler sa ses
échecs et tour f 6 et tourcoing ismat ça
à tanger les noirs je vais dans quel
sens vers leur âge je vois je vois
jamais les positions quand c'est comme
ça ça me saoule
j'aime pas quand ça tourne trop
l'échiquier ça se passe quoi si je fais
juste fou g5 est d'un machisme atsé
m'attend 2 c'était facile ça doit être
dame ces deux d'impro f2 je peux pas
faire d'un preuve je suis cloué world
j'avais pas du tout ouais mais je prends
et je prends des huit du coup ça
français 8 tu fais dame c5
[Musique]
mais pourquoi pas d'âme ses cinq sur
dame b si j'ai tour à 8 et sur b 6
échecs
est / psg tour c'est ça des chats croix
b 8
j'ai rien et tu sais quoi du coup le
coup là
ckb 5a je suis mauvais bon allez on en
refait je suis là en ce moment là qu'est
mon pour le moment ça va
il est très facile et ça ça gagne la
tour là en maths
là il n'y a rien pour lui là ça m'a donc
vraiment on a des très facile à laïque
et prend des quatre épreuves trompant
sur échec la cetam f1 en bref un match
là c'est tout reproche trois dames 3 3
dames première dame franges et un match
c'est facile ça ils menacent le fou il
menace assez petit rock
maintenant il ya la tour à deux reprises
a su aller trop vite dans ma vie tu
mates tout reprend h6 j'ai voulu j'ai
voulu accélérer de quatre ans et six
tours francs v8 ont comme dirait car on
peut gamble une fois d'en mettre trois
dames 3 h 3
entourage suite d'un projet 6 en fait
c'est cela seul truc pour gagner parce
qu'on est cloué c'est un premier set qui
va lui aussi se souvient 5 et
d'apprendre cette maths c'est cet échec
crois j'essais ton mathon dame s'est
prise prise
quel assez prises prise j'ai pas trop
compris la suite et si tu souffres deux
cas ces cavaliers à 6 échecs et dames 37
matchs et jolie là
là je sais pas
j'ai aucune idée je sèche totalement je
vois pas c'était juste 7 au rang des 8es
la dame est enfermé
dans ses sept tours en des 8es la dame
est enfermé dans ses tours 17 et la dame
était enfermée j'ai pas vu c'était
facile c'était tellement facile
c'était tellement facile
[Musique]
c'était tellement simple abusé jusque je
découpe bizarre et c'est déstabilisant
quand il joue que des coups de merde
jusqu'au bout un juste aux 3 juste un
mec cap damev deux tours qu'on lave de
hockey pour le moment ça va à ok comment
ça se passe ça se passe ça se passe qui
est un v6 d'athlétisme à des épaulettes
quel on va donner un petit échec il ya
un math cas ces dames ses huit fois ses
traits à prendre des huit cas c'est tout
francs des six tours prend dé cet échec
j'étais pas sur ce qu'il fallait faire
après ici c'est d'écarter fou à quatre
ans ferme la dame ok ici c'est d'amener
cinq cavaliers h7 maths ça va le roi
prend f6 c'est facile
la c3g 6 juste mais on apprend facile
ici cavalière trois échecs qui est des
deux matches dams ranger 3 échecs dames
cran et cavaliers h quatre matches ici
qu'est cette âme français 2 et tour des
huit hockey ici d'amanites échecs dames
france et huit enfants et machin fois
fuite fait foi 6 ici dame prend h trois
échecs et tour g8
ici mark iii et ça gagne ici on fait
d'un van roy prend non
il faut voilà assez d'alex tanguay
chèques émanant des six mais l'idée
c'est que 6 et que ouais bon je vais pas
le temps d'expliquer ici
ces cavaliers des quatre échecs pour 30
ans français devait tomber un math ici
je trouve pas
je trouve pas du tout j'aurais pu jouer
tempo 1 c'est pas qu'elle prend des
quatre ici que ces prises pour abc c5
ici c'est tourcoing h7 est fou prend g6
et mâcha ici c'est un étranger de kef
quartier troncs des trois allées d'un
nouveau ici c'est fouet f3 la mach 5 et
fo prend à eux deux et foucque 31 et
florent machin ici on a les blancs c'est
fou prend les six s'étaient cavaliers
des 6 es fou pranger 6 ici
à
les stages si c'était facile en fait ici
s'achète un premier écart ici c'est y
entrant ici d'un projet huit tours
projet cet or g8 pour g7 matt ici
bon bah a fait que 38 ouais ils sont
tous très facile ans enfin dernier ou
pas alors c'est enfin là et il ya le
droit qu'a commencé mon nez complètement
fou ouais ça fait cher quand il y arrive
mais ce qui est dur et c'est le sait que
c'est que tu cherches pas toujours la
même chose et le niveau le niveau d
exercice est différent c'est mélanger et
peut y avoir des trucs simples compliqué
pas assez fou de matane un [ __ ] c'est
abusé de le rater voilà justement à
jouer sur celui-là
je voulais aller trop vite j'ai voulu
aller trop vite
complètement ratée suis là bas mais tout
gagner va les faire tour f 1 à l'efo
faut réessayer
[Musique]
j'essaie trop gamble dans le précédent
j'essaye de trop gamble
ok bon pour le moment ça va ok comment
ça se passe il faut faire gaffe parce
qu'il y avait la turquie étant prise de
l'autre côté hockey vraiment ça va
ok
j'aurais pu aller plus vite pour
celui-là à l'eal très haut noir comment
on fait
je vois pas d'autre chose que français 3
pas facile à damas trois dames 3 2 d'al
des cinq et on gagne une pièce 3,8 damas
huit dames c'est si ce qui est des sept
dames b6 d'amd 8 qui est des cats assez
facile dans macadam pranger 4 il faut
juste sous des 3.5 ok ça du juste
d'acheter mais cette quête bessac
intermédiare dame français 2 qui et
c'est ça que ça doit gagner et prend 17
ici ils français 4 puis on prend re est
ok issifou b 3 échecs et 3,5 hockey ici
tour b 1 et tours b 8 au pied ici
si je bloque aa je vois pas ce que ça
peut être qui est tous gagnent mais je
vois pas ce que ça peut être c'est relou
de bloquer là je sais pas
juste aucune idée on dit qui est proche
des 4 es ok ça gagne un pion merci le
chat qui est bref 3
[Musique]
le nouveau bloqué sur un truc facile en
fait j'ai nouveau bloqué sur un truc
facile
bon alors espère le tournant
pas facile hein pas facile ce truc
c'est papa évidence ce puzzle rush
alors on joue contre ta boule bull lee
trop facile un peu trop addictif wes un
peu addictif
alors qu'est ce que ça donne ce tabou le
boul
essayer de jouer vite mais bon faut
vraiment que je sois en forme forme pour
pour faire un bon score
pas assez en forme aujourd'hui je rate
quelques trucs faciles je blogue sur des
exercices
comment on rejoint alors faut être sur
le club faut être sur le club ché scam
français après aller dans rejoindre un
tournoi l'a toujours été mais toi
le tempo mais c'est dur ce puzzle rush
pour le mans joue très mal je pense mais
bon on verra plus tard
peut-être qu'on augmentera le niveau
atteint l'ensemble j'ai rien rien voir
j'espère que ce sera mieux pour l'aréna
de demain puis c'est une royale c'est
d'autant plus important
simplement je pense que je vais super
mal
mince j'ai ouvert le nom propre liens
qu'on peut ré ok on n'a pas des pendules
comme j'ai cadré recadrer des cadres et
on n'a pas les pendules alors quel est
des deux qui a fait reculer à cinq je
m'attendais à ce qu'il fasse tout est
fait en fait
on va voir ce qu'il va faire c'est pas
faire me fallait ce que je suis en train
de jouer dans tous les cas
je sent pas la patience je ne sens pas
la patience et l'envié de gagner pour le
moment peut-être que ça viendra pour le
moment j'ai eu ni l'un ni l'autre
j'ai pas les ingrédients pour gagner des
parties même contre des joueurs plus
faibles j'ai pas la niaque j'ai pas le
le puzzle rush qui m'a qui m'a pourri le
cerveau il faut vraiment que je
réussisse à le faire en étant à tête
reposée pas fameux je défends mon pions
et on fout et un peu précaire c'est pas
fameux encore pense à la new team ouais
je pense à la new team bien sûr très
importants avec un briquet ans et
qu'avant laon la réception ça j'avais
pas vu évidemment à 1 on va perdre et
c'est sur c'est sûr qu'on va perdre
aux échecs comme dans tous les jeux
comme dans tout si tu met pas les
ingrédients pour l'emporter
ça peut pas marcher 1
c'est comme dans tout si t'as pas la
concentration les envies et tous ça
passera une d elle une belle victoire
pour ta boule bull en attendant ça sera
de coupe pour lui faut encore qu'ils
tiennent pas ce que je vais pas je vais
pas me laisser mourir non plus un
faux-pas faut pas non plus déconner donc
il va quand même devoir l'a gagnée alors
ok il veut il veut rajouter 2 de la
tactique à la tactique ce qui est jamais
une très bonne idée quand vous avez une
position avantageuse retour des 8
quand vous êtes mûr ajouter de la
tactique à la tactique c'est pas pas
forcément l'idée du siècle à la fois
c'est sûr tour 17 vous prend des six
tours 3 6 tc 500 francs v6 qui est
francs 17 tours bouger mon cavalier
défendu donc je peux faire ça
semble-t-il n'est il pas une bonne idée
et surtout que il a pas max de temps
donc il rajoute de la tactique à la
tactique qui l'assomption de plus
forcément il va devoir utiliser du temps
pour calculer la même si je calcule pas
très bien malheureusement grosse
différence de niveau donc même pas en
forme normalement je calcule pas trop
mal mon jeu peu raté des trucs 1 mais du
coup maintenant il va voir la pression à
la pendule parce que si jamais il lui
reste plus qu'une minute sera pas facile
à conclure et donc là en fait il a
rajouté toute cette tactique pour
finalement que ma tour se retrouve sur
une bonne case et il a raté f4 et donc
ils repèrent son pion et maintenant j'ai
la paire de phu bài d'hommage à il était
il était proche du gagnant c'est pas
fini il faut qu'il s'accroche faut qu'il
s'accroche
mais bon maintenant il est une pas une
superposition il faut sont bien calés
c'est dur à jouer comme il est il a
perdu du temps alors petit coup de pouce
et 2 est-ce que c'est désagréable
un peu hein parce que ça ça menace quand
même deux pièces l'a immédiatement à ce
que je disais en plus plus l'utilisent
de temps puisque met sous pression
maintenant moins d'une minute
il va très probablement prendre en c2
donc ça nous permettent encore de lui
près move on aurait zone dangereuse
après quand on approche des trente
secondes que me reste beaucoup de pièces
sur l'échiquier c'est dur dommage elle a
perdu voilà il a cherché à s'embêter
dans des tactiques alors qu'il ait
réussi à prendre le dessus je vais pas
je n'ai pas joué de manière très
brillante et c'est dommage après move
c'est dommage parce qu'il avait il avait
la partie en main tout en préparant le
met sous pression
c'est pas très bon à sa crise de pions
mais ça nous permet de pré move près
vous ferez m'ouvre la paperie en d5 ce
qui était pourtant le coup logique alors
est ce que là il va faire quand même
puis on programme des trois noms donc il
me punit pas et je vous c'est lui qui a
perdu des tempo
alors on va venir avec fougue et 4
maintenant damas 5 c'est pas terrible
mais c'était pour voir ce qu'ils
faisaient
donc voilà il a pas mal joué on n'a pas
joué un truc très fort
on va devoir donner ça et faire baisser
un peu pourri on espère fou détroit
comme ça dans l'accueil c5
mais bon il prend on va reprendre 2
c'est en ayant l'espoir de fixer le pion
c est donc maintenant car à lieusaint au
caire malgré tout renseignement est en 1
il a créé il a créé un pion arriérés
donc on va aller lui dire bonjour mais
ce n'est pas forcément exceptionnel mais
bon on réussit à mettre nos pièces sur
des bonnes cases donc
mais se parle c'est ce que si ferrari
aurait dû qu'à l'idée de d'ailleurs qui
peut traîner ça qu'on le met un peu en
dedans j'ai directement pensé qu' ses
arriérés le pion qu'automatiquement
maintenant le visent
et on lui fait mal pour s'inscrire il
faut s'inscrire au club 1 d'abord nos
jours et ensuite tu pourras
et ensuite tu pourra rejoindre ses
options ces trois-là carrière alouettes
ballon là on l'a mis en sueur un
alouette baba là il ya tout l'héritage
de france qui sont autour de lui et qui
lui dit zissou quoi tout qui a réfléchi
plus d'une minute
il a joué fou eux deux un peu par dépit
parce qu'on lui fait beaucoup plus
logique et il rajoute pas tempo alors là
faut faire gaffe on va faire cavalier à
6 et on va essayer de s'amuser un peu
on va essayer de s'amuser un peu
est-ce qu'on tente un truc qui marche
pas trop mais qui est drôle way it is ou
hills où ça marche pas du tout mais
c'est marrant quoique food et un ça
marchait mais ça c'est ce qui m'embêtait
je pensais qu'ils allaient faire food et
et si je dis que ça marche pas du tout
ce que mes pièces non sont très mal
placés et que l' attaque marche pas
vraiment donc c'était mal joué mais on
le savait donc bon pas de déception
on savait que ça marchait pas donc c'est
ça l'avantagé quand tu veux un truc tu
sais que c'est mauvais on le joue en
sait comment t'est pas déçu d'avoir une
mauvaise position après tu sais que tu
es dans l'esprit à fond tu sais que
c'est mauvais donc t'es pas été pas la
dire ouais je me retrouve mal j'ai fait
une connerie ou quoi tu le savais ça ça
te donne vraiment un avantage sur les
adversaires ça ok alors la whey ouais
alors là c'est dur
dames 1 roy f3 il n'y a que dalle donc
on doit reprendre là mais là on est
vraiment très malin on savait à quoi
s'attendre mais on pensait peut-être pas
que ce soit si grave
faire un petit coup de tours est un
échec au passage j'ai atteint ma
tondeuse
non
voilà c'est sacrément grave mais on a
voulu tenter le marantz mauvaise pour
faire le beau jeu ça paye pas toujours
le beau jeu
problème dans la bas dans la vente avec
dame b3 un problème c'est quand tu fais
qui arrive cet qui disent ici contrôler
la casse c4 ok donc là il ya quand même
des menaces pour les blancs qui sont
assez pénibles ce qui arrive cet qui est
d ici ce dont j'ai envie de dire on va
devoir jouer à 6 on est vraiment très
mal et tout ça j'ai vu passif et dame
prend est-ce qu'on souffle ou pas
normalement on est quand même content de
jouer cette finale vu que le roi était
tellement aux abois
s'ils voulaient le roi était tellement
mal que le fait d'échanger les dames
ça va permettre de tenter les pions pas
ses pions pas s'éloigner contre les
pièces mineurs c'est pas mal cavaliers
h4 j'aime pas trop de base mais il veut
revenir vers eux cinq ils fait fou des
six ok on va faire froid aussi son
s'activent
ok quand le l'espace rebelles roi ici on
va pousser pour le moment un petit peu
ok
on va faire tour échec à il va y avoir
cavaliers f3 qui sauf à lachamp classe
ça c'est vraiment pas de chance ce qui
l'avait pas vu on va faire j'ai cinq
échecs et g4 hockey bref cette et là il
ya un genre double attaque
ok et maintenant on va pousser les pions
vers dame
qui est le roi qui revient encore
on va le faire tomber
arrières fou prend aux la la qu'est-ce
que je suis bête oh là là là là à
écouter on méritait de perdre
oh la la quel idiot j'ai oublié
souffrent aïe aïe aïe grâce arrive
fallait bien perdre ça arrive ça arrive
bref c'était manque de concentration
enfin c'est pas très grave
c'est pas très très grave alors là on a
encore foutu mais on va essayer de jouer
dans l'esprit à fond ils sont là quand
même largué une pièce plus tôt dans la
partie
pas facile hein
j'ai eu un moment j'ai joué en fait
sinon j'aurais gagné
enfin bon c'est pas grave mais qu ils
subissent un jour sans vie de ces gens
n'ai absolument rien à faire enfin pour
se vêtir ça va embêter vraiment encore
perdu cette partie j'aurais pas fait
exprès de donner ma pièce en 1 un peu
plus tôt pour m'amuser un jeu vous
rigolez jeu pour rigoler c'est pas
important
demain que ce sera important pour
l'aréna royal là on s'en fout voilà on a
encore foutu peut-être la perdre aussi
ça la voix est ce qu'on voit si et anna
tout vu ou pas allez on va laisser on va
on va voir on va voir s'il a tout ce que
je pense qu'ils voulaient faire qui est
bessin il pourrait à ses maths mais à
qui france f4
alors il a sa finale avec un pion de
plus on va voir s'il est capable de la
gagner
en effet avec un repli plus en plus avec
une bonne position
donc ok comment est-ce qu'on peut
essayer de sauver ça c'est pas facile
alors il est vraiment très mal là on est
vraiment très mal c'est un peu too much
comme essayé de la défendre alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut essayer
d'embêter fourbe et 4kids et 58
kas est vraiment foutu 1
je pense pas la perdre c'est là aussi
mais bon là j'ai vraiment mal jeu ça
fait deux parties je fais ce prêt du
matériel faudrait que j'arrête faudrait
que je joue correctement
parce que c'est que je donne des
handicaps à chaque partie mais là c'est
ok la précédente j'aurais dû gagner mais
là du coup je me suis pas du tout
concentré et c'est vraiment complètement
foutu comme ça c'est un peu too much
enfin se reconcentrer à partir de la
suivante c'est trop facile à gagner ça
c'est trop beaucoup trop facile à gagner
enfin rejouer sa faim sérieusement un
peu plus sérieusement
on dit qu'il ya 7 1 0 non je pense pas
qu'il dise ça qui prime c'est tour g8
donc et c'est complètement foutue 1 mais
ben ouais c'est pas mal joué quatre des
huit je passe ce tour des huit c'était
bien joué aussi puisque sur cavaliers 5
et rfo f4 mais ça c'est bien joué aussi
bon faut cette affaire qui est aussi son
affaire roi c'est ici cfa et des quatre
affaires roi ici
ok mon bref si l'on va essayer sur tour
des six d'avoir b5
on va être complètement trois pions -
quoi ah ouais non mais ça partait de
trop loin ça partait trois faucons
rouges ou sérieux faut reprendre un peu
de confiance
ouais mais c'est 15 complètement foutu
c'est une horreur je met le rang
ces 8 afin que je vous dise vertueux
quand même plus sérieuses que ça
c'est vraiment pas remarquable ça
m'agace que là j'ai vraiment mal joué
nous est enfin l'autre jeune tour et là
j'ai juste donné la partie dès le début
quoi tu sais le truc à elle que 5 et
très mauvais bonds
j'aime pas trop donner des parties
gratuites comme ça ça me déplaît
ça ça m'énerve au plus haut point de vue
des partis comme ça c'est juste
tellement ridicule mais ont jusqu'à me
lisez pas de pas de motivation pas
d'intensité et du coup c'est pas
étonnant
et du coup c'est pas étonnant de perdre
comme ça c'est assez normal en fait
si tu fais rien de spécial pour gagner
c'est normal de perdre comme ça
[Musique]
c'est quand même très très foutu cette
histoire
je pense je veux apprendre 3 toute façon
mais c'est beaucoup trop fichu
alors comment récupérer 1 2 pions et de
bon ok c'est toujours perdants mais un
peu moins alors on va faire froid c'est
le x e 5
m6 a encore complètement foutue malgré
malgré notre combat
bon
c'est à dire de moins en moins à perdre
dans cette histoire
je suis pas sûr que je vais faire fou
pour un an jusqu'à 3 500 que le croiser
le roi s'activent trop
mais je peux prendre l'a4 intermédiaire
sur échec pas que je prenais une fourche
atteint parce que c'est possible
ma l'otan et la position est tellement
dure à jouer depuis longtemps
depuis beaucoup de coups je veux dire qu
est ce possible de s'en prendre une
ok on va sécuriser son rapide ses
enfants allaient comment allez c'est pas
mal ça c'est pas mal ça faisait quand
même réveillé un moment donné parce que
c'était abuser c'est abusé il a bien
fallu se réveiller et s'en sortir les
killers magna mais c'est de refaire
pareil du coup enfin voir si ça repasse
à l'essai mauvais mais on va s'amuser à
lille rennes paris fier à 5
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe ils prennent pas les
pièces les enfants quelle incroyable ça
je leur fais les gros cadeau tu leur
donnes des pièces en un il et prennent
pas pas très courageux tout ça c'est
incroyable ça on n'est pas contre des
apôtres du beau jeu hein
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
ces enfants là alors hein ils veulent
pas prendre les pièces en un bon alors
on va on va continuer à forcer un peu le
destin
enfin peut forcer le destin quand même
mais bon c'est faux vous bossiez au
final les enfants ça va pas
alors comment est-ce qu'on peut
l'embêter le maximum je pense vous
commencez par kg ici si on veut
l'embêter mettre la dame ans essaie de
faire grand roque m lada manger sain coq
et suivant ce qui fait
pas sûr sûr on va on va essayer de
l'attaqué
hockey amical face aux rois rejouer j'ai
pas vu j'ai pas vu faire dame e set rock
elles sont les nouvelles partie d'alpha
0 du coup son roi pourrait être mal
acquis leur manière on va voir mais bon
ceci parce qu'il refuse de prendre les
pièces en lin donc ça c'est un problème
quand même qu'ils leur manière
l'effet d'amd 4 et j'avais envie de
m'amuser en faisant grand roque quand
même en lui laissant le pion à 7 et puis
on ramènera la tour en g8 on va laisser
on va laisser ramasser j'ai envie de
vous dire les amis les amis au nom le
missclick oh non mais ça coûte cher ça
quand même quand tu sacrifies quand tu
fais des gants vie comme ça la tour en
g8 ça change tout là quand même
olala assez désespérant ouais mais bon
on a la même avec un temps moins quoi
aïe aïe aïe
ah ça change vraiment tout ça change
vraiment tout
ces grosses différences bien évidemment
alors maintenant
comment est-ce qu'on mène cette attaque
d'un match 4-3 dommage j'aurai une belle
variante urru damage quatre cavaliers f3
damas trois pions prend cavaliers f4
échec 3 h un tour prend h3 et qu'un
voyage de qui défend c'est vrai je suis
sinon c'était assez joli on doit quand
même faire d'un match 5 je pense
mais ça aurait pu être très jolie sinon
pour faire le beau jeu hein
c'est très très dommage et on va tenter
un truc marrant va essayer dame c4
avec l'idée de faire cavalier f4 sur b3
c'est exactement l'idée et menaces tour
pranger de roy h un tour prend h trois
cavaliers h2 mais cette fois ci aura
tout reproche de maths
donc ça c'est le beau jeu les amis ça
c'est le beau jeu les amis une nouvelle
fois une grosse convergence sur le roi
adverse
car qui est des quatre quarts aile et
des quatre qui défend
car est-ce qu'on peut tenter un truc
jolie si on fait tout reprend j'ai deux
rois h1 et d'amd 3 améliorer dame prend
des 3a
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de beaux là
pour faire du beau hockey en faire
cavalier projet de peut-être c'est joli
ça et puis sur pions prend fera cavalier
prendre trois et quel point m c'est joli
qu'à l'étranger de ces jolies j'espère
que c'est une belle partie les amis
on va prendre trois
on va prendre des trains on va prendre
c4 a fait retour à cinq et on va
préparer l'arrivée de la tour de ce côté
ça on va encaisser à 4
et on aura besoin de plus à commencer
par tour des huit pour éviter les échecs
c'est pas forcément utile on va prendre
maintenant ici on va revenir on a cinq
et on va repartir de l'autre côté on a
environ des cinq fait un petit échec et
on va encaisser le cavale et ben voilà
une belle partie alors on rejoue contre
et anale et on va lui faire f 4
ça de mémoire en fait c'est pas très bon
pour les noirs je sais ce que je joue
mais je crois que c'est pas très bon
je sais plus exactement comme on veut
jouer avec les blancs c'est pas mon
répertoire
je suis pas sûr d'avoir bien joué du
tout là je pense même l' inverse ce que
je pense que les joueurs mettent le
stream mois est très possible
on a fait une belle partie la contre
killer magna c'était sympa comme parti
enfin trois cas je pense qu'il joue h6
mais j'aurai à j'aurais fouet ce
qu'attend affaires de trois fous détroit
et si on finit le développement on a un
pion central en plus un
j'imagine qui veut faire fou prend un ok
c'est pas mal joué ce qu'il va faire il
joue pas mal hein il joue pas mal mais
aurait pu faire cailler eu quatre
intermédiaires je pense il va avoir une
bonne position si fait cavalier 4
maintenant il va avoir une bonne
position
ou pas d'ailleurs je faire roi b2 et à
cavaliers avec deux bonds à lancer de
nouveaux faits magouilles et avare et
c'est celui de vagues houllier
normalement il doit pas prendre la tour
direct c'est bien jouer normalement ne
soit pas l'apprendre direct dans le sens
où
il joue bien dans celle là il joue pas
mal hein parce que roland kobia les deux
qui sont en prise
tu perds un temps quand tu quand tu
quand tu la prends parce que sinon il y
avait une fourchette et donc fallu être
normal on attend qu'une des deux tours
bouche pour la manger alors essayé de se
battre à fond cette position pourri donc
vous n'êtes pas vraiment un scream
pédagogique on joue on joue un peu on
joue un peu n'importe quoi
et après on essaye de sauver dans des
finales et dans les trucs différents
alors là peut-être fou bref c'est tfou
prend 1,8 quand même qui semble
récupérer le matériel le petit piège qui
a été tendu et qui a marché
ok ok et pranger 2 ok
alors tu es projet c'est pas mal joué
dans le sens où il veut ressortir en
bouffant un truc
alors qui est française histoire en
marche pas du tout à faire bouger 6 il
va prendre prendre et on va sauver le
pion eux comme ça
on va sauver le pion heureux pendant
surprend g6 et la tour g1
est ce que laurent va nous faire un
petit retour sur carlson caruana je sais
par un tgv à vie mais c'est pas toujours
facile d'avoir ce genre de personne je
pense que laurent va le faire il faut
que lui demande mais quand il aura le
temps
enfin je sais pas si vous imaginez en
fait à chaque fois qu'il va faire tout
rejet un tour pranger 2 et 2,5
je passe vous imaginez le fait d'avoir
une flat pendant tous les pendant tout
le match que c'était des fois je ne sais
pas o'keeffe a ramené le roi vert 4 rêve
de tous réussissent assez réussie c'est
très mal joué
il va payer pour il va payer pour ne pas
gagner ce sont aujourd'hui mais les
souvenirs comme toujours les arénas et
séparément c'est très important je vais
ramener un peu le roi
on va faire tout rage 6 s'il ya plein de
gagner le pion h5 tout en protégeant le
pion h 2
les rois b3 et on est tranquille ou
refaire un échec et anne qui peut
toujours pas monté leroy pascal à titan
fils alaa et à une fois qu'ils bossent
ces finales en finale et hans et le sait
le festival 1 c'est le festival et
l'éteindre en finale il a du mal hein il
se fait tourner de folie en finale en
finale il se fait il se fait masser de
pauvres
le pauvre le pauvre et à lille se fait
masser en finale
cros énorme cette facilité de réflexion
ouais encore là je peux te dire que je
ralentir vraiment ralenti là tu vois je
suis au diesel je paye la taxe carbone
là bas j'ai envie de te dire j'ai envie
de te dire on l'appelle la taxe la taxe
carbone au 1er janvier je la paye dès
aujourd'hui là je suis je suis malin je
suis pollueurs quand je joue comme ça je
pollue un maximum à faire très très
attention
on va prendre camp rock on va voir ici
et jouer sur ce clou âge qui va être
pénible à à régler bon on va faire un
petit peu mieux joué sur le clouage
d'affaires 5 au prochain
la bo xi mokssit en sueur alors allez
hop on va finalement réussir à jouer sur
ce clou âge elle cavaliers qui va tomber
pas encore d'ailleurs pas sûr mais
surtout réussi je veux faire re 5 quand
même j'aime ça se fait tout reprendre 5
je prends un f6 et s'y prend du plomb je
prends un f6 et je prends des huit aller
tout réussit ce sein que c'est fort je
pense violents balayant sur bo xi en
sueur elle abandonne tonton méthane qui
est quand même devant nous un ça c'est
dur à sézanne à séduire ses arénas si
t'as pas le le bon appariement on va
faire x 6 tours j 8 et on aurait mater
mais on a perdu une partie un peu bête
contre alouettes baba tout à leurs
gamins ça abusé mais bon ça devait bien
arriver un
en joue contre et tan tan qui doit en
avoir marre de nous tan qui dans l'avoir
complètement marre cette fois-ci 6 me
laisse au prochain jeu reprend sûrement
prendre on va se développer
en plein développement
on va prendre une fois c'est bien joué
je pense de sa part me joue pas mal hein
il joue pas mal en milieu de jeu et
annie joue bien donc on repart avec un
pion de handicap
à écouter je suis taquin je lui laissais
à 7 tu peux rester ici c'est puis je
vais essayer de faire ce que je peux je
veux voir un peu comment il joue au
milieu d'eux je trouve qu'ils jouent
bien en milieu de jeu par une position
tactique ouverte comme ça je pense qu'il
va faire une bonne partie le petit ethan
mais on essaiera quand même lui taquiner
la truffe on va voir
ok alors là dessus et ce que je fais roi
c'est cette jeunesse damas cinq je vais
leur en but 8
on va justement faire ça
rendez 8 est quand même mieux placé et
surtout des deux caves a lieu quatre
comme ça je mets un peu f2 sous pression
et je menace qui est prend des deux fous
b4 en force
et sur ces trois j'aurai tout reprend
s'il a repris de la dame
donc là je crée pas mal de menaces quand
même
qu'avaient les d4 qui semble défendre
pas mal de choses
roquet et des cas c'est bien joué parce
que turquie prendre des deux dames prend
des deux fous bk tuera c3 et surtout
reprend des cas tuera encore dame prend
des quatre ça va ça va tenir alors prise
prise
si je commence par ces cinq ça va pas le
faire alors peut-être faut que je joue
pouces et 7 en premier et surtout ses
sept premiers comptent peut-être faire
d'amd 4 ok je trouve pas comment si je
fais c'est ça qui fait cavalier là si je
fais pousser cette île fait d'amd 4 et
sur dame prend fou prend ses 5 à f3 qui
se voit
ce que c'est moi qui trouve pas ou est
ce qu'il n'ya rien
est ce que c'est moi qui se trouvent pas
ou est ce qu'il y a juste rien
je pense que c'est moi qui trouve pas
tout cas c'est bien défendu
ok je peux peut-être fait reprise est
fou 1,5
ça n'a pas marché non plus
ça marche pas non plus
match de ma part et adam eux deux
j'avais peut-être quelque chose
adam 2 qui défend
et c'est étonnant ce que je pensais pas
que ça défendrait mais ça défend et sur
machin mb400 leïla le tendre au quai à
chaque fois grâce étonnant mais ce qu'il
y avait vraiment quelque chose puisque
étant un cas de figure assez bizarre où
il y avait rien qui passait bien sûr
tours 8
dans sa défense alors maintenant ce
qu'on va faire c'est pas entrer dans une
finale avec un pion de moins mais un
petit peu d'activité du coup ce sera un
bon exercice pour itan ce soir sur les
finales tournoi à thème pour ethan j'ai
envie de te dire c'est quasiment un
cours particulier qu à ce niveau là six
mois là c'est quasiment un cours quoi
ok offerte aux deux tempos radio et b5
vite
bien joué
très bien joué même croire les trois
c'était le bon coup ça aussi c'est bien
joué a menacé une fois ici on va faire
un coup de b4
ok pas mal pour le moment il joue bien
c'est peut-être la finale qui réussit le
mieux quand même le faire tomber au pire
a en tout cas on espère auquel on la
gagne et ça ça me paraît quand même
c'est compliqué un nouveau une nouvelle
finale en fait pas réussi à lui faire
des pièges
ça n'est nulle part alors on va
reprendre on va reprendre les
fondamentaux les colonnes ouverte
l'empêcher de doubler sur la colonne des
tueries laurent b 6
j'apprends de l'espace ici
alors comment il se débrouille on peut
pas vraiment doublé sur la septième pour
le moment
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal c'est bien
joué pour le moment ils se débrouillent
pas une option qu'elle craque à cheval
juste pas vu qu'elle lui non plus tu vas
faire un échec ici
ah mince et moi je n'y ai plus de temps
ouais c'est dommage qu'ils aient plus de
temps je vais essayer de jouer à un truc
plus technique mais malheureusement le
manque de temps force à jouer le flag
caisse et bien jouer non il ajoute bien
celle là et cette flaque quand même hein
ce que flag est un état d'esprit
flag est un état d'esprit les amis les
amis c'est un peu déplorable mais on va
flag
bon ok j'en suis pas fier il aurait
mérité de la gagne et ce à la salle elle
aurait mérité de la gagne et j'ai assez
mal joué j'ai mal joué la finale j'ai
voulu gagner un truc que j'aurais dû
faire nul aurait été mérité faire nul et
ça est bien sorti dans ce mail a mieux
joué que moi mais bon j'étais bien
obligé de flag c'est bien obligé de flag
pas le choix quoi pas de chance abbas
était marrant moi fier j'ai réussi à
perdre une c'était la première défaite
je crois dans ses arénas où la deuxième
contre l'alouette baba donc pas dommage
pour moi mais bien joué et bien joué à
lui donc félicitations alouettes
j'aurais pas dû donner set qui a duré
dix plus mon monde de cruauté quoi et
puis va sinon c'était marrant ce trois
finales contre et anne
ouais ça fait plaisir de la gagner
c'était juste pour embêter et anne il
aurait tellement mérité la nulle pas du
coup on se retrouve demain soir sur la
chaîne big three à partir de 21h pour
l'aréna et je sors un peu plus en forme
qu'aujourd'hui je pense pour jouer c'est
un petit peu un petit peu limite mais
aussi manque de motivation ça joue aussi
beaucoup sur ce les mecs bas plus à
demain soir
ciao ciao merci d'avoir suivi